[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regarder
les chèques et mondiale sur rt France au
sommaire aujourd'hui la transition
énergétique censé freiner les
changements climatiques ce processus se
trouve actuellement au croisement dont
je environnementaux géopolitique et
économique ou en étant actuellement dans
la transition vers les énergies vertes
la COP 26 qui se tient à Glasgow viens
de fermer ses portes le 13 novembre sans
aucun résultat tangible les états de se
mettre d'accord ni sur les délais de la
sortie du charbon ni sur la réduction
des émissions de méthane ni sur l'arrêt
de financement de projet d'énergie
fossile à l'étranger la conférence et
aussi marquée par la tension croissante
entre les États-Unis et la Chine les
deux plus grands pour l' heure mon duo
en terme de CO2 s'accuse depuis
plusieurs années début environnementaux
l'Union européenne quand elle essaie de
mettre une pression économique sur
nombre de ses partenaires commerciaux
dont la Russie et la Chine un an trop
d'huile dans la taxe carbone c'est
transition énergétique en cours affecter
les pays de l'OPEP à fond des tenues et
les conséquences néfastes pour leurs
économies les Émirats arabes unis et
l'Arabie Saoudite et la Russie adopte
des objectifs écologiques ambitieux
néanmoins le peuple Freddy le rôle
dominant du pétrole sur le marché
énergétique dans les décennies à venir
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur ce processus au cœur de l'
agenda écologique mondiale c'est le
Blitz la transition énergétique actuel
4e de l'histoire moderne consiste à
réduire l'utilisation des combustibles
fossiles profite d'énergie renouvelable
solaire éolien hydraulique et d'autres
ce processus passe par la transformation
de tous les secteurs de l'énergie de la
production à la consommation finale
l'objectif est de limiter les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre afin d'attendre
la neutralité carbone le plus rapidement
possible c'est-à-dire un équilibre entre
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
c'est absorption par les écosystèmes
l'Union européenne et les États-Unis
content de venir note en carbone d'ici
2050 pour la Russie et la Chine
l'objectif est l'année 2060 l'Inde se
fixer l'année 2070 comme date butoir
pourtant les émissions mondiales de CO2
continue d'augmenter selon les données
de la Banque mondiale lâcher les
États-Unis sont de loin les deux plus
grands pollueur en terme d'émissions de
dioxyde de carbone ensuite viennent
l'Union européenne l'Inde et la
Fédération de Russie
la transition énergétique réchauffe de
plus en plus les pensions sur les
tickets mondiale m'ayant permis aucune
avance est majeur la récente Coop 26 est
devenu le théâtre d'une confrontation
diplomatique entre les États-Unis et la
Chine tout en augmentant leurs émissions
de CO2 et la production de charbon les
deux poids lourds géopolitique s'accuse
mutuellement de dégâts environnementaux
pour l'Union européenne la transition
énergétique et aussi une occasion pour
mettre la pression sur certains de ses
partenaires économiques la nouvelle taxe
carbone européenne pour écouter à Moscou
plus de 1 milliards de dollars par an ce
passage progressif vers les énergies
renouvelables risque en outre de privé
les puissances pétrolière d'une source
de revenus majeur en cherchant à éviter
les conséquences négatives pour leurs
économies les pays de l'OPEP
investissent de plus en plus dans les
énergies vertes or dans les années à
venir le peuple contre conserver le rôle
dominant du pétrole sur le marché
mondial
comment la transition énergétique
est-elle instrumentalisé à des fins
politiques et économiques pourquoi le
passage aux énergies vertes au niveau
mondial où en sommes-nous dans la course
à la neutralité carbone pour répondre à
toutes ces questions nous rejoignons ses
mails sur Ferrari professeur de
géopolitique de l'énergie et président
de la société européenne des ingénieur
et industriel monsieur sur Paris Bonjour
bonjour bonjour à vous et aux auditeurs
il
faut d'abord pourquoi la dernière clope
26 n'a-t-elle pas produit de résultats
tangibles selon vous
merci si on a eu 26 sais que c'est
difficile si j'étais quelque chose de
simple on aurait résolu pas en
1995 avec la présidée par la mère
qu'elle est très difficile de trouver
des arguments parce que l'énergie est la
base de notre vie l'énergie c'est la vie
change energy il y a plus de vie et donc
dire qu'on va tout changer brusquement
pour faire plaisir aux activiste mais
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour qu'on
ne le pense et
c'est toujours la même chose on prépare
avec beaucoup de propagande pour faire
les enchères mais ensuite ça finit
toujours de la même façon avec des des
conclusions qui sont comme
mademoiselle
du bla-bla
parce que oui ça avance mais surtout les
émissions de CO2
depuis qu'on fait des cartes on organise
des coques les émissions de CO2
augmenter de 58 % plus de 2 % parents et
donc vouloir dire qu'on va à résoudre
cela
international ça me semble utopique
d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai écrit est-ce
qu'il faut attendre la 80 19e pour
constater que ça ne marche pas je ne
sont pas les coques qui vont résoudre
les émissions de CO2 ce n'est pas
possible si ce n'est pas ce ne sont pas
les coques qui vont résoudre ce problème
alors c'est quoi
il faut considérer que
le monde a besoin d'énergie et que donc
vouloir dès qu'on va réduire les
émissions de CO2 signifie qu'on va
devoir réduire la consommation d'énergie
l'énergie c'est la même notion physique
la même notion physique que le travail
énergie et travail c'est la même chose
ça s'exprime avec la même unité
d'ailleurs ce sont des jongles donc
vouloir dire qu'on va résoudre réduire
les émissions de CO2 se réduire les
émissions d'énergie fossile
réduire le travail dans le monde c'est
impossible c'est simplement impossible
et surtout que on a on observe à présent
que les énergies dans une blague Paribas
une limite devant tout le monde on voit
bien que les liens et le solaire ne
parviens pas à remplacer les énergies
fossiles et donc continue à dire qu'on
fait d'accord pour penser l'éolien et ça
ne marchera pas que c'est ça marche pas
c'est la décroissance
veut dire revenir en arrière et certains
le propose bien entendu c'est la
limitation de la population en a qui
revient au même avec la dépression
qui est une solution certainement qui
permet de réduire les émissions de CO2
mais je me fais pas d'illusion
se développer et donc
oui où se trouve aujourd'hui la clé de
la transition énergétique est-ce que
selon vous il y a des pays qui font
encore obstacle aujourd'hui
si on parvenait à trouver cela
c'est tout bénéfice pour tout le monde
et surtout ce qu'ils auront développé
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que le
pense d'ailleurs je voudrais insisté sur
le fait que il n'y a absolument rien de
neuf dans tout cela cette transition
énergétique mon la cherchons depuis 73
avec les chocs pétroliers de 67 et 79 on
a commencé à parler de transition
énergétique de nouvelles solutions
d'énergie alternative d'énergie
renouvelable non pas à cause du
changement climatique mais à cause des
crises du pétrole depuis 50 ans bientôt
on a investi énormément et qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait on est arrivé en Europe à
avoir 2,9 pourcents d'énergie éolienne
et et solaire on voit bien que ça ne
marche pas et donc il faut
résoudre la transition énergétique comme
ça là que quelques conférence ou
quelques directive européenne c'est
beaucoup plus que ça merci beaucoup
monsieur sur Paris nous allons
poursuivre notre analyse tout de suite
mais nous retrouvons à la fin de cette
émission pour plus de détails sur ce
thème merci encore
la COP 26 s'achève donc sur impact bien
terne après 2 semaines de négociation le
13 novembre les États se mettre d'accord
pour réduire progressivement
l'utilisation du charbon et accélérer
les objectifs qui m'a pourtant pas de
mesures concrètes ni de réalité les
fixer car les désaccords sont encore
nombreux
sur 197 est à présent à la Coop 2644
états s'engage accélérer lors des
efforts pour sortir de l'énergie au
charbon parmi les grands absents de cet
accord si ton la Chine l'Inde et les
États-Unis principaux producteurs de
charbon au monde plus de son pays se
sont engagés à réduire les émissions de
méthane 2 - 30 % d'ici 2030 la Chine la
Russie l'Australie l'Inde et l'Iran
s'abstiennent le projet qui prévoit de
mettre fin au financement à l'étranger
de projets d'énergie fossile ne fait pas
non plus l'unanimité seul une vingtaine
de pi prenne cet engagement
cette conférence et aussi marquée par
une tension croissante entre deux des
plus grands émetteur de CO2 les
États-Unis et la Chine le président
américain venu à la conférence critique
la décision de son homologue chinois de
ne pas y participer en personne
franchement cela a été une grosse erreur
pour la chaîne de ne pas être présente
le reste du monde à regarder la chaîne
et a dit qu'elle va le rapporte-t-il
d'ailleurs Washington n'a pas caché son
objectif de presser pékin lors de la COP
26 quelques semaines avant la conférence
États-Unis et le Japon s'entendent pour
demander à la chaîne de contribuer
davantage aux efforts mondiaux de
réduction des émissions de carbone la
critique American engendre une vive
réaction de la part de Pékin qui
reproche à son adversaire son manque
d'action
la Chine soutient sincèrement climate
action ce n'est pas nous qui nous sommes
retiré de l'accord de Paris les
États-Unis ont cependant rétropédaler à
plusieurs reprises sur leur politique
climatique au lieu de rejeter le blâme
sur d'autres ce qu'il devrait faire
maintenant c'est assumer leurs
responsabilités et prendre des mesures
concrètes
pour
la pression sur la Chine
septembre 2020 à l'ambassade des
États-Unis en Chine publie un rapport
qui accuse pékin d'être le plus grand
voleur du monde en termes d'émission de
CO2 la principale source de débris marin
est le plus grand consommateur de
produits de bois l'ambitieux projet
chinois de la nouvelle route de la soir
et particulièrement pointer du doigt
celui-ci engendrerait de lourdes
conséquences environnementales
côté chinois la réponse ne s'est pas
fait attendre pékin publie sa propre
liste d'accusation visant les autorités
américaines le document mets en avant le
fait que les États-Unis ont été mis plus
de CO2 que tous les autres pays dans le
monde non seulement il est très peu
contre le changement climatique mais
selon pékin il boude aussi l'action
mondiale dans cette direction parmi
d'autres reproches fait à Washington
figure le manque de transparence le mot
respect des engagements sur la réduction
du CO2 et le refus de ratifier un
certain nombre de traiter environnement
allez proche de Washington l'Union
européenne se montre aussi critique
vis-à-vis de Pékin et euro cours en plus
haut pression économique en juillet 2021
Bruxelles annonce son intention de
mettre en œuvre un mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières des
2026 toutes entreprises européennes ou
non se situe en or de l'Europe exportant
vers l'Union européenne un certain
nombre de produit polluant sera soumise
à une taxe carbone la Commission
européenne ne le cache pas à cette taxe
coûtera cher à la Russie le CREN la
Turquie la Biélorussie la Chine et
d'autres la presse russe évalue les
pertes de la Russie a 1,1 milliards de
dollars par an Moscou il voit une
violation des règles de l'OM c'est et
dénonce l'instrumentalisation de
l'agenda climatiques à des fins
politiques
notre diplomatie devrait s'opposer plus
activement aux tentatives de l'Union
européenne et des États-Unis de
s'arranger le droit de dicter
individuellement l'agenda climatique et
de formuler des normes sur ce
néanmoins en imposant sa façon
d'accélérer la transition énergétique
aux acteurs externes
semble elle-même divisé sur le sujet
mais octobre 10 pays membres de l'UE
emmener par la France demande à
Bruxelles de reconnaître le nucléaire en
tant qu'énergie vers d'autres pays comme
l'Allemagne et l'Autriche ou le
Luxembourg sur pause en évoquant le
danger que peut représenter le stockage
à très long terme des déchets
radioactifs l'utilisation du charbon et
un autre sujet de discorde en septembre
la République tchèque saisi la justice
européenne pour obtenir la fermeture
d'un site polonais en raison de son
impact sur l'eau Bruxelles en une amende
à Varsovie mais les autorités polonaise
refuge de fermer les mines de charbon
concernant ces divisions temps au niveau
européen qu'au niveau mondial à risque
de s'aggraver en raison d'une
concurrence a cru sur les marchés des
terres rares ces matières sont
handispensable au développement des
technologies vers or aujourd'hui c'est
la Chine qui contrôle plus de 80 % de ce
marché
afin de briser se quasi-monopole chinois
les 4 pays du quad savoir les États-Unis
le Japon l'Australie et l'Inde s'accorde
en septembre dernier pour coopérer en la
matière Washington finance lui-même le
développement de ce secteur à l'interne
Bruxelles oui appelle les États membres
intensifier l'investissement dans la
production des terres rares afin de
réduire la dépendance de Pékin alors
comment la transition énergétique
peut-elle affecter les pays principaux
producteurs des énergies fossiles quel
obstacle se dessine sur la voie vers le
passage aux énergies vertes comment et
pourquoi la 4e transition énergétique
a-t-elle commencé la réponse après la
pause
[Musique]
bien qu'elle fasse l'objet d'un
engouement croissant les énergies
renouvelables ne sont pas une idée
nouvelle le soleil levant la chaleur de
la terre l'eau on peut toujours et
exploité par l'homme pourtant la
transition énergétique verset source a
débuté relativement récemment au début
des années 1970 des préoccupations
croissante pour l'environnement au
niveau international aboutissent à
l'organisation en 1972 à Stockholm une
conférence des Nations Unies sur
l'environnement à l'époque les
climatologue Salernes d'ailleurs plus
d'impossible refroidissement climatique
que d'un réchauffement de la planète la
Conférence de Stockholm et non des
principes visant à concilier
développement économique et gestion de
l'environnement dans le cadre d'une
coopération internationale à cet effet
une nouvelle structure est créé le
programme des Nations Unies pour
l'environnement de plus les tenues de
sommet de la terre tous les 10 ans
réunissant les dirigeants du monde
entier au sujet des questions climatique
et environnemental est décédé dans les
années dix-neuf cent programme des
Nations Unies pour l'environnement
s'inquiète de la pollution atmosphérique
responsable des pluies acides puis de la
dégradation de la couche d'ozone c'est
problématique dans un lieu au protocole
d'Helsinki en 1985 est de Montréal en
1987 signée par un nombre croissant de
pays qui s'engage à réduire leur
démission nocive à partir de 1988
l'attention de l'organisation se tourner
vers le réchauffement climatique et les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
contribue le Sommet de Rio en 1992
marque une étape importante à cette
occasion est adopté la convention-cadre
des Nations Unies sur les changements
climatiques signé par plus de 160 pays
qui se fixe pour objectif de stabiliser
les concentrations de gaz à effet de
serre dans le même cadre est institué la
Conférence des Parties la coque qui
rassemble tous les ans à partir de 1995
les représentants des signataires de la
Convention la Coop de 1997 vois la
signature du proton qui auto fixer un
objectif de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre pour les pays
industrialisés devant entrée en vigueur
en 2005 ça portait est atténuée par le
refus des États-Unis de le ratifier de
plus la Chine l'Inde ou le Brésil encore
considéré en 1997 comment développement
ne sont pas concernés afin d'atteindre
les objectifs du protocole plusieurs
solutions sont envisagées en particulier
l'utilisation a cru de source d'énergie
renouvelable dans la production
d'électricité
cependant les technologies concernés
essentiellement l'éolien et le
photovoltaïque sont encore peu rentable
à l'époque de plus leur caractère
intermittent les rangs peu attrayante
afin de stimuler leur développement
d'importantes subventions lors sont
accordées sous des formes diverses
notamment en Europe conformément au
protocole de Kyoto les marchés du
carbone semaine également en place à
partir de 2005 le principe et
d'attribuer des quotas d'émission de CO2
aux acteurs principalement les
entreprises quota quelles peuvent à leur
tour revendre où acheter le but étant
densité les industriels et plus émetteur
à réduire leur démission de carbone et à
se tourner vers des technologies propre
ces différentes mesures entraîne une
forte croissance des énergies
renouvelables dans les pays
industrialisés au cours des années 2000
en 2015 la cop21 aboutit à l'accord de
Paris qui tente d'élargir les objectifs
de décarbonation de l'économie à
l'ensemble des pays compris des
économies émergentes les États doivent
élaborer des contributions nationale
décrivant des objectifs climatique
cependant ses contributions reste
volontaire en fonction des contextes
locaux et pays émergents se montrant
réticent à prendre des engagements trop
contraignant susceptible de freiner leur
développement économique la Chine
notamment se fixe l'horizon 2030 pour
parvenir à un pic de ces émissions de
CO2 de même l'Inde dans un rapport
estimé qu'elle n'atteindra pas son pic
démission avant 2040 au cours des années
suivantes les codes successives cet
achat la mise en œuvre de l'accord de
2015 ainsi qu'à citer les pays à prendre
des engagements ambitieux la transition
vers de nouvelles sources d'énergie
pèsera inévitablement sur la demande en
hydrocarbure c'est ce que prédit
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
dans son rapport publié en octobre 2021
selon celui-ci la demande en charbon et
en fait troll baissera vers 2050 à
Nevers laquelle le prix du baril
pourrais descendre à 24 dollars les
prévisions des industriels sont
similaires ainsi le géant pétrolier
britannique BP prévois une chute de la
demande de pétrole dans tous les
scénarios l'avenir de l'or noir sont
donc sombre or les pays producteurs ne
sont pas d'accord avec ces prévisions
ainsi le peuple ne vois pas
d'alternative au pétrole d'ici 2045 et
certaine qu'il conservera son rôle
énergétique dominant il est prévu que la
demande globale de pétrole augmente de
17,6 milliards de barils par jour entre
1020 et de 1045 à 100 de 90,6 milliards
de barils par jour à 108,2 malgré cette
confiance dans l'énergie fossile les
pays producteurs de pétrole de s'y
investissent massivement dans les
énergies vertes en octobre dernier les
Émirats arabes unis s'engage à atteindre
l'objectif de zéro émission vers 2050
c'est le premier Petro États du Golfe à
faire une telle promesse pour y arriver
Abu Dhabi prévoit 163 milliards de
dollars d'investissement dans les
énergies renouvelables sur 30 ans
l'Arabie Saoudite montre aussi ses
ambitions elle permet de générer 50 % de
son électricité via des sources
renouvelables des 2030 la Russie est sur
la même voie mes annonces des objectifs
plus modestes le PV atteindre 10 % de
renouvelable dans son mix énergétique
vers 2040 au lieu de 1 pourcents
actuellement
c'est attachement afficher aux énergies
propres n'empêche pas les pays de l'OPEP
de défendre les hydrocarbures à
l'international leur principal arguments
en faveur de ce qui assure une grande
partie de leurs revenus est l'importance
du pétrole et du gaz pour la sécurité
énergétiques mondiales c'est ce que
souligne le PEP en réagissant à
l'adoption du pacte de Glasgow sur le
climat
l'équilibre délicat entre la réduction
des émissions l'accessibilité financière
de l'énergie et la sécurité énergétique
nécessité politique globale et durable
en écoutant et prenant en compte toutes
les voix se focaliser sur l'un au
détriment des autres peut mener a des
conséquences inattendue a des
distorsions du marché à une volatilité a
cru et à des déficits énergétique en
effet récemment les crises énergétique
ont confirmé la vulnérabilité des
énergies renouvelables qui ne peuvent
pas assurer un approvisionnement stable
en énergie
au début de l'année en février le Texas
connais une vague de froid inhabituel la
température chute jusqu'à - 8 degrés
Celsius la demande en énergie pour le
chauffage Bondy mets le secteur
électrique a du mal à générer les
quantité suffisante les turbines
éoliennes sont gelées alors qu'elle va
sur est 42 % des approvisionnements
autre source majeur d'énergie le gaz
souffre aussi de troupe de production
résultats le prix du gaz Bondy en étant
x 200 et celui de l'électricité par 360
cet automne des facteurs similaire main
à la hausse des prix du gaz en Europe
durant l'année 2021 la production
d'électricité par les éoliennes chute à
travers l'Europe à cause de l'absence
inattendu des vents les centrales
hydroélectriques souffre aussi car la
chaleur dessèche les rivières en
parallèle cette même chaleur accélère la
demande en énergie en était forçant à
puiser dans les réservoirs père de gaz
avec la baisse des livraisons tout cela
amène une demande accrue en combustible
bleu ce qui propulse les prix à des
niveaux encore alors la transition
énergétique est-elle réalisable au
niveau global dans les délais prévus
pour y voir plus clair nous revenons
vers Samuel sur Paris professeur de
géopolitique de l'énergie président de
la société européenne des ingénieur et
industriel
farine peut-on dire que la transition
énergétique se retrouve de plus en plus
au centre du jeu géopolitique
aujourd'hui
les choses
du 21e siècle va être déterminé par les
consommations dans les pays émergents et
notamment l'Inde et la Chine l'Inde et
la Chine ont des besoins gigantesque en
matière d'énergie raison pour laquelle
ils ont
bloqué en quelque sorte la conclusion de
la Coop 26 et donc ces pays vont avoir
une croissance de l'économie et de la
demande en énergie
phénoménal ce sont eux qui vont
déterminer
s'il y a des solutions nouvelle elles
viendront de la parce que on a besoin de
se solution sinon ils continueront à
utiliser les énergies bon marché bien
entendu et donc même si nous deux
Monterey, yeux dans l'Union européenne
ce qui n'est pas impossible mais qui va
coûter très cher
prends pas nécessairement est donc
celle-là qui est la dimension
géopolitique on va pas se battre sur
l'approvisionnement des du pétrole comme
on l'a fait il y a 50 ans c'est pas le
sais plus à la politique c'est de voir
qui va déterminer le futur de l'énergie
et comment bien entendu si l'Australie
continue à dire que elle va pas entendu
à tous ceux qui veulent l'acheter
c'est-à-dire l'Inde et la Chine en
particulier mais forcément le charbon
dans continue à se développer et
interdire complètement le charbon
de manière sérieuse et pas simplement
regardé concernant la transition
énergétique forsen opposetel pas trop de
risques selon vous on l'a vu
dernièrement par exemple avec la la
crise gazière qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez mais je ne voudrais pas l'appeler
parce que c'est simplement le
fonctionnement du marché et nous vivons
pour l'instant il y a pas une prise de
rupture comme dans les années 70 c'est
le prix qui augmente parce que là
on va plus dans des nouvelles un
peu plus normale dans quelques temps
donc c'est différent par contre ce qui
ce qui est important de remarquer dans
la puissance et que justement la demande
engagé exceptionnel dans le monde parce
que le gaz et on peut en faire beaucoup
de choses et il aimait beaucoup moins de
CO2 et surtout il n'a pas de pollution
atmosphérique donc derrière votre
question là on voit poindre
l'importance du du gaz naturel dans la
nouvelle situation énervé monsieur sur
Paris dernière question peut-être cette
reprise de croissance économique après
la crise du covit va-t-elle selon vous
enterré complètement tous les espoirs de
cette transition énergétique et il faut
pas être magnifique c'est par là où
l'autre nous allons dans un monde où on
a besoin d'énergie on a besoin de toutes
les énergies prenez l'exemple de la
Chine la Chine est les champions en
matière de charbon
enlever des Champions je veux dire elle
consomme énormément en matière de
charbon elle et elle consomme énormément
de gaz
produit également de plus en plus de
réacteurs nucléaires
c'est bien tu as besoin également de
l'hydro électrique
il ne faut pas
c'est là le gros problème d'aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on veut passer de 0 à 100
rapidement laissons le temps et les
choses et on fera des choses dans plus
intelligente le message principal de la
transition énergétique elle ne se
décrète pas elle se construit avec la
science et la technologie
l'innovation conduire des progrès bien
entendu et cette innovation il faut la
poursuivre avec beaucoup de recherche et
surtout stimuler les jeunes n'ont pas
avoir peur mais à faire des études
scientifiques les études d'ingénieur de
manière à construire un avenir de
développement durable le développement
durable ça se construit avec de la
science et de la merci beaucoup Samuel
sur Paris pour cette analyse votre
éclairage aujourd'hui je rappelle
semaine sur Paris professeur de
géopolitique de l'énergie est président
de la société européenne des ingénieurs
et industriels et et aujourd'hui avec
nous cette partie-là n'est pas encore
terminé la semaine prochaine et une
nouvelle partie nous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondiale
à bientôt sur rt France